you are watching coalface channel
welcome to a special episode of Kult
Houston thinking if you think about it a
lot of the inventions of the past 100
years have been eclipsed by one device
the smartphone this is the remember
series a time where we take a look back
at some of those inventions and how we
got to where we are today
please enjoy our episode to the point
and shoot digital camera classic
point-and-shoot digital cameras were an
integral part of society for the better
part of two decades and most of us
remember having a digital camera at some
stage priceless captured everlasting
moments from the personal lives of many
people around the world are all owed to
one device before the advent of the
digital camera when you took a photo you
have no way of really knowing if that
shot was good or a total mess once
you've taken the shots that you needed
you had to send your images off to a
physical photo shop and then you have to
wait to get the film developed the
digital camera was a silent revolution
in of itself of course those were
Polaroid to see images instantly but it
was really digital photos that were a
new type of creation immortalized in
ones and zeros because I've got
technology behind me and 50 snaps on
this tiny little bit swapped back in the
Japanese have been threatening for over
two years to launch an electronic stills
camera which would enable you to take
pictures like this straight onto the
disk without the need for any processing
well they're still working on the camera
but the disk as you see has certainly
arrived what's more these pictures will
last forever
they won't fade and they'll never get
scratched but where do the technology
for the digital camera come from and how
they're starting to disappear so fast
today's smartphones can do some things
that even many standalone digital
cameras can't we'll take a look at the
state of the art at the end of this
video but first the beginning
most people think that the digital
camera was an invention of the 1980s but
his origins actually began in the
previous decade the story begins in 1974
with a young engineer working at Kodak
his name was Steve Sasson one day
Steve's boss gave him a new kind of chip
and a camera and asked him to do
something with the both there was really
just the keep Steve busy at the time the
chip that was handed to Steve was a CCD
or charged coupled device and it really
is the heart of the digital camera at
the time the CCD was a new experimental
invention but was also unique as it
could store large amounts of information
by converting light into electrical
charges that could eventually be stored
as data
the idea was revolutionary at the time
but the question was could he store
images with this data in essence
replacing the century-old film or the
CCD Steve's set off to find out Steve
and a lab technician James Lafleur used
old circuit boards chips from a
voltmeter and old lens to attempt to
create this first digital camera there's
a lot of work ahead of them they first
had to get the device to work at all
then they had to try and figure out how
to digitize the signal and then
eventually they had to find a way to
read the digital signal and convert it
into an image it would be the recent
1971 invention of the microprocessor
that would help with that last part it
took a few months and weighed 3.5
kilograms the by December of 75 they had
a prototype but would it work there was
only one way to find out these two weary
guys needed something to take a photo on
and the first photo subject happens to
be a female lab technician that also
went to Kota once the photo was taken
and after she took 23 whole seconds to
record the image
and when the image came out from the
screen it wasn't the greatest quality
and I was actually pretty distorted but
the boys were ecstatic and they were
happy that has it worked at all the
technician whose photo was taken wasn't
impressed and simply stated that a need
of more work
Steve soon discovered that he'd
accidentally crossed him wires and when
he uncross them the image became clear
and with that final moment the digital
camera was officially born Kodak didn't
show much interest in the technology
however if we really think about it from
their point of view why would they Kodak
had been making film for 136 years at
the time
so film and film development was a huge
part of their business model the digital
camera story continues in 1976 it would
be the military that would independently
fire the first real life application for
the new technology it came in the form
of the spy satellite at the time
retrieving film canisters and the issue
of limited film capacity were two very
real problems now of the CCD the images
could be transmitted to the ground with
a crystal-clear resolution of 0.64
megapixels or 800 by 800 pixels as the
years went by the military began to use
digital cameras more and more and in
soon scientific fields picked up on a
technology and then later still medical
applications by the late 1980s the media
and newspapers had got on board
in fact the small size of digital photos
made it possible to transmit photos via
phone line out from Communist China
during the Tiananmen Square protests in
1980
however digital cameras are still very
expensive for what he actually got for
example in 1991 rhetoric brought to the
market kodak dcs 100 it had a 1.3
megapixel sensor and a bulky external
digital storage system it was prostitute
very cheap $13,000 and that's about
twenty two thousand seven hundred
dollars in today's money very cheap
but of course by the mid to late 1990s
the price began to drop and subsequently
the use had widely spread to the common
user what can it picture be well it can
be whatever you want it to be it can be
on paper or not
[Music]
a picture can be whatever you want it to
be because now Kodak gives you the power
to take pictures further the turning
point was in the 2000s at this point
film cameras have been largely replaced
by the younger digital counterparts but
how did we get from the 2000 to them as
you all know the most common form of
point and shoot digital camera currently
resides in that computer in your pocket
the smartphone before continuing is
worth noting that 90% of mobile phones
use a CMOS sensor it's a technology that
came of age in the late eighties in the
early 90s
it's similar to CCD but cheaper to
produce and does have a few issues such
as rolling shutter during video capture
let's continue the first camera phone
was actually by sharp it was called the
J phone and it was released back in 2000
it could take a whopping 20 photos at a
resolution of 0.1 one megapixels you can
feel the photos on his 1.5 inch LCD
screen but getting the photos off the
phone was much more effort than it is
today
now I just want to show you a little
something before he continued I found a
2001 BBC report of the very curious and
equally ridiculous idea of putting a
camera on a cell phone this report was
about the j phone itself just listen to
some of the comments that were written
13 years ago Joanna from Finland says a
picture shooting cellphone certainly is
a curious invention
it could be handy for delicate
investigation or infiltration who would
know to look for a camera on a phone
list from the UK writes infinite uses
for the teenager not entirely sure what
the rest of us will do
but Julian from the UK is right on the
money he says it's an obvious move
eventually all portable gadgets phone
camera comm computer must come together
in one communications device and how
right he was
so it's interesting to see how society
axis such early versions what would
later become common to pretty much
everyone as we all know as the 2000s
flowed on the cameras got sharper the
phones got smarter and more
full-featured for much of this decade
each passing year saw a steady
improvement in the image technology and
innovation by 2010 you wouldn't be too
disappointed if you had to rely on a
fund rather than appointment shoot
camera 2011 store a few ill-fated ideas
come into play
stereo graphic 3d and both LG and HTC
made that mistake today in 2014 it's an
employee different word we have learned
to 41 megapixel senses place focusing
cinemagraphs Adorama's HDR burst modes a
small detection face detection and a
whole lot more so today we now have a
camera with us all the time we can
instantly capture the amazing the
shocking with just the little personal
things that make us who we are all of
this at anytime anywhere instantly it
hasn't always been like this so it's an
interesting title
[Music]
anyway that's the program for today if
you'd like to see the history of the
video camera and the part is played in
our lives please check out the first
link below anyway until next time don't
forget to give a thumbs up comment and
subscribe I'll see you again soon for
the next video
cheers guys cold fusion
it's me thinking